there's a local medical facility that
puts our seniors wellness at the center
of attention here's more
so let's talk about central well and who
you guys are introduce us
so central is a network of one-stop shop
centers for our senior focus primary
care and we have eight locations total
in the las vegas valley
now you got us covered all across the
valley and what does center well mean
when people drive by
what does that big sign mean so center
well was
originally named partners in primary
care but has
switched to center well to better
capture our focus on wellness for our
senior patients
and you mentioned senior focused care
what does that mean to the community
senior focus
means easier access to appointment times
usually
same day or the next day appointments
and it also
means shorter wait times in our lobby
area and longer
times with the provider so we can get to
know each other
so what other unique services do you
guys provide our local seniors
so for some of our senior patients they
get
lonely or they have financial struggles
some of them will have food securities
and we provide
all that support as a team collaboration
wow and mentioning team here i know you
guys have a special
thing called care teams at your
facilities what does that consist of
so a care team if you will you can think
of it as a football team
as the provider we're the quarterback we
run the plays we watch everything we
oversee everything but
there are other people such as the
clinical pharmacist that will go over
all their medications to see if there is
any interactions
um as i said there's a resource
coordinator for food insecurities
and things of that sort wow taking care
of our seniors i love that and i love
the football analogy that was good
doctor
where can people find centralized like
we said they're across the valley
so central you can go to
seniorfocuslasvegas.com
the website again is
seniorfocuslasvegas.com to find the most
convenient location for you
we have eight in the valley currently
and more to come
awesome and i understand that you are
accepting new patients
absolutely great great people are
you know still a little reluctant to
come into facilities
i know that it is the perfect time to
come in and see a doctor right
yeah so for our patients who are 65 and
older we would like to see them
every three months just to make sure
everything's okay to prevent them from
going to the urgent care or the er
and for the annual wellness visit it's
important to have
once a year to go over everything from
head to toe
all your preventative screening and make
sure you're in tip-top shape
we have telehealth visits so they have a
smartphone or a tablet
you can do a video conference i know
some
patients may not have that and so we can
also do a telephone visit as well
all right call centerwell senior primary
care at 702-766-4910
or visit seniorfocuslasvegas.com
las vegas now will be